[Music]
today we canceled national geographic i
mean really we could cancel national
geographic simply for rebranding itself
as nat
geo a few years ago and shifting all of
its television programming over to
reality shows
the national geographic channel should
be nothing but nature documentaries and
documentaries about primitive tribes
people in the amazon
that's all anyone ever wanted from
national geographic
they don't want whatever nachio gives us
now and what they give us now includes a
heavy dose of far left
racial propaganda of course the most
recent and egregious example of this is
something called the race card
project which the company recently
unveiled to give you an idea of the tone
and tenor of this thing the editor of
national geographic
susan goldberg recently sent out a mass
email to readers
promoting the project and she signed the
email quote
sincerely susan goldberg editor-in-chief
national geographic
race card white privileged with much to
learn
so here she is literally playing the
race card but for a white person playing
the race card means apologizing
non-white people can play the race card
in order to gain
sympathy and privilege white people can
play it in order to be further demeaned
and degraded and as we've discovered
many white people in this country have a
masochistic
fetish for that sort of thing so they're
more than happy to play the card
and accept that treatment as for the
race card project itself
nachio rolled it out on twitter and uh
here's what it says
it says ten years ago michelle norris
launched the race card project which
asks people to describe their feelings
on race at just six words
she thought few would respond here are
some of the responses out of half a
million so far
that she's received and from there
natgeo highlights several people of
different races who describe their
lived experience to use the leftist term
in six words
um we'll go through some of these that
they highlight
first we have a black man isaias uh
maritab who says
black boy white world perpetually
exhausted
and we're told that his parents came
here from ethiopia and you'd think that
he'd be quite grateful to be in this
country living a life of comparative
luxury and privilege
and not in ethiopia but no he's
exhausted
so exhausted it's exhausting living in a
first world country well-fed
with all with access to all of life's
comforts and luxuries it's so exhausting
just exhausted all the time then we have
mark quarles who's a black man who
chooses these six words with kids
i'm dead alone thug
also there's hannah peoples who says i
am not an exotic
creature hannah is not white but we
aren't told what her
ethnic identity is apparently the fact
that people can't
look at her and immediately know her
country of origin is its own form of
persecution we're told quote
hannah people said that constant
guessing game about her identity as well
as the harassment and unwanted attention
she's received from creepy men make her
feel like a specimen
her six-word story was born of
exasperation
exhausted exasperated
then we have gene tagaban who's a native
american who says
native americans america's invisible
invisible
invisible this one struck me as a little
bit lazy
i mean he's given six words and he can
only think of three so he repeats one
three times so it's got like native
americans
america native americans america is
invisible
no actually you get six words oh okay
well uh then america's
invisible invisible invisible
there are a few white people featured
but compare their self-description
with the descriptions offered by the
minority participants white guy daniel
robbins
says ashamed that accomplished
minorities surprise me
he's given six words to describe his
experience as a white man and
one of the six he chooses is ashamed
same for lindsay heydrich who's a white
woman who says i'm ashamed for my
ancestors race
apparently she had ancestors who were
slave owners
she's she's ashamed not of their
behavior
but of their race and her own
the only commonality between all these
responses is that everyone is dejected
and sad and complaining they're all
living in the most prosperous and freest
country in world history they're all
unimaginably privileged when compared to
almost everyone else who has ever lived
anywhere on earth
they're all clothed and fed and doing
fine and yet their perception of their
experience
is completely negative for the minority
respondents
they're angry about the alleged
persecution they suffer at the hands of
whites
although none of them can give a
compelling example of persecution one of
them is annoyed
because people can't guess her ethnicity
on sight
and the other guy's exhausted because
although life is a hell of a lot better
than it would be in ethiopia
it still isn't perfect and the lack of a
perfect life is exhausting
meanwhile the white people are ashamed
ashamed of themselves even though they
can't really explain
what they've done wrong so just think
about this the minorities are sure
that white people are doing them wrong
but can't explain how
the white people are sure that they've
done wrong but can't explain what
they've done wrong
everyone is sad everyone is mad only the
white people are ashamed
and nobody knows why they feel any of
this
it's all quite sick and gross and
perverse and it shows you to what extent
many in the american public have been
brainwashed this is one of the most
telling signs of brainwashing
when people hold firm often
self-destructive beliefs but they can't
explain why they hold those beliefs
it also shows us that our culture is
suffering from i think a cataclysmic
crisis of meaning while our comfort has
increased in our collective wealth and
luxury has also increased
we've turned from god and we've turned
from traditional faith and we have found
our lives empty and purposeless
because of it i mean that's the real
reason why people are so sad and
depressed and riddled with anxiety that
they can't explain
but the left's racial dogma gives people
a framework for understanding that
anxiety it's the wrong framework
but a person without meaning a person
without purpose will grasp on
to anything that seems solid and
intelligible
even if only superficially intelligible
because this is all the result of
brainwashing it's probably useless to
engage with it intellectually but i i
will anyway
just on this one point the idea that
white people should be ashamed
of their whole race because of the past
bad at bad behaviors of some white
people
is completely insane even if white
people were uniquely evil in history it
still wouldn't make sense to be ashamed
or apologetic for your race
you don't inherit guilt and sin through
skin pigment
your great-great-great-grandfather's
sins are not your own
even if his skin color is but as it
happens
and this is very crucial to understand
white people were most definitely
not uniquely evil in history
what after all are the evils that white
people are supposed to be
so ashamed about slavery
conquest genocide racism well first of
all conquest isn't always a bad thing
sometimes it's a good
thing for one civilization to be
conquered by another i gave the example
last week of the aztecs who themselves
conquered and slaved
their tributary states and force them to
provide fodder often women and children
for human sacrifice
there's a reason why when the spanish
came here they were able to easily
enlist
neighboring tribes to defeat the aztecs
think about that you've got these
strange creatures who have
landed from an unknown land and
the the the other native american tribes
many of them easily quickly fell in with
the spanish
and said yeah we want to help you take
these people down
everyone hated the aztecs because they
were a brutal murderous
dictatorial regime but the point is that
however you feel about conquest whites
did not invent it
we didn't even introduce it to this side
of the world
white people didn't introduce slavery or
racism either
these are humanity's sins they've been
practiced or committed
by all people everywhere through all
history
the the unique thing about the united
states relationship with slavery is that
we abolished it in less than a century
whereas some parts of the world
many of them non-what non-white took
millennia to do the same
some people still have not effectively
gotten rid of the practice
as for racism racism again is a foible
of humanity
all humanity across time
and it is today far more prominent and
far more accepted and far more
mainstream
in non-western countries
if white people should be ashamed then
everyone
everywhere should be ashamed all the
time
either that or we can all move on with
our lives
and we can deal with the present and we
can let the past remain where it belongs
whatever choice we make as far as that
goes
the one choice that i certainly can make
today at least
is to say to national geographic you're
cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated